hi
everyone
when we
hear
his
[Music]
every month
who makes means
he's crying for you
now
he wants sexual
[Music]
them blue scary
behind me
oh my god
scary ass
just that quick game
offer me
[Music]
if you've played majora's mask 2
completion you probably remember all too
well the darkness that that game holds
within its pixelated world you probably
remember all too well the song called
the elegy of emptiness which is
responsible for creating one of the most
disturbing images in zelda history but
if you're newer to the franchise and
maybe haven't played majora's mask or
haven't heard of the infamous
creepypasta named ben drowned allow me
to explain what the allergy of emptiness
is real quick as the events of the game
unfold link eventually finds himself
facing off against the long dead king of
ikana whose name is igos du icana and
upon defeating the undead emperor is
taught a strange tune this tune gives
link the power to create quote a soldier
who has no heart empty soulless copies
of himself that take on whatever form
link was currently in as statues meaning
if he was wearing the zora mask and
therefore was zora link then the song
would create a zor link statue and so on
and so forth for the dq and goron forms
this tune is called the elegy of
emptiness and pretty much every aspect
of the song is self-explanatory i mean
it creates soulless duplicates of link
like a 3d snapshot picture as motionless
statues using some sort of ancient
mysterious magic what's not to
understand well if that was all there
was to the story it wouldn't have been
talked about so heavily for the past oh
two decades or so the reason that the
elegy of emptiness is such a creepy
topic is because of what the statues
look like when they're created see out
of all the neutral appearances for the
statues that the game's developers could
have gone with they decided to go with
some genuinely creepy design choices
instead the kind of which are so
deliberately different and deliberately
bizarre that they must mean something
the elegy's duplicate statues look far
different than any of link's forms this
is actually very obvious if you think
about it the deku statue isn't wearing
any of dikulink's green clothing nor
does it have his blonde hair and its
pose is stretched out almost as if it's
reaching out for help the goron statue
is also not wearing any of link's green
clothes that goren link wears and is
additionally wearing a black beaded
necklace instead of goron link's blue
beaded necklace and has a giant scar
across its abdomen where goron link does
not the zora statue has one completely
tattooed arm and a single bracelet on
its other and again is not wearing any
of link's clothing additionally all of
the statue's facial expressions are
quite alarming as well the deku statue's
expression is sad the goron statue's
eyes are completely white and the zora
statue's eyes are also white with its
mouth wide open in somewhat of a
horrified gasping expression now this is
all very strange because the other forms
that link takes on don't have any of
these features or facial expressions
except for maybe deku link but that's
hard to tell because deku faces all kind
of look the same but as veterans of
majora's mesqulor will probably agree
with me on you know who these statues do
actually look like the dead people that
link got his alternate four masks from
which would specifically be the deku
butler's son the goron hero darmani iii
and the zora rockstar mikao the son of
the deku butler is already dead at the
beginning of the game having been killed
by the skull kid in order for him to
curse link so we don't get to see what
the little child looked like in life but
in death the tree that the sun has
turned into has sad eyes and three
leaves on top of his head the same as
the deku statue darmani appears to us in
game as a ghost unwilling to leave the
mortal world until his soul is healed by
link playing the song of healing after
which his soul departs into death but we
can see that he wore a black beaded
necklace in life and had a large scar
across his abdomen the same as the goron
statue we do actually get to see mikael
the rockstar living although it is only
for a few moments as he dies soon after
meeting link in life though mikao had
one completely tattooed arm and a single
bracelet on his other exactly like the
zora statue and the fact that the goron
and zora statue's eyes are white as
opposed to their living forms being
black implies that the statues are
taking the form of a soulless or dead
body do you see what i'm saying now it
would be a simple case of oh the elegy
just makes a blank statue duplicate of
link but because of these deliberately
strange designs of the statues there's
obviously something going on more than
what we thought initially it would be
like if every time i took a picture of
myself which is supposed to create a
digital duplicate of my image it came
out looking like a dead person every
time which would be so creepy and
strange that i'm 100 sure that not a
single person would even try to pretend
that's normal in my opinion the same
logic applies for the elegy of emptiness
and its statues since these 3d snapshots
take the forms of not link but the souls
that gave link has alternate forms who
are all dead at this point it can be
assumed that the mysterious power of the
elegy of emptiness attempts to create
duplicates of souls instead of bodies i
mean this has to be the case for two
reasons one mikao's physical body is
shown evaporating in front of our eyes
and therefore does not even exist
anymore and two the deku butler's son's
body has a tree trunk instead of legs
but the deku statue has legs instead of
a tree trunk which we've never seen in
game so where would the elegy of
emptiness have gotten the zora and diku
forms from if their physical bodies are
forfeit well to me this means that when
link plays the song while wearing a
transformation mask or in other words
while wearing a body that is not his
original body the elegy must be reaching
beyond link in the mortal realm into the
realm of death where it searches for and
locates the original soul connected to
the body of the one playing the song and
then becomes a physical snapshot of that
soul and we know it has to be an
up-to-date immediate snapshot of the
soul in death because of the goron and
zora statues white eyes which we never
saw before they passed on implying their
current state of being dead at the time
of the allergy being played alarmingly
none of these soul snapshots look
particularly happy meaning that even
though link healed these people's souls
and allowed them to pass fully into
death they still look horrified i guess
the afterlife isn't as peaceful as you
might think now i'm sure you've noticed
that i haven't been mentioning the
biggest part of the elegy's creepiness
and that would be the duplicate elegy
statue for link himself as in the one
that materializes when link isn't
wearing a transformation mask and is in
his own body this statue is so bizarre
and so unnerving that it is primarily
what spawned these countless theories
over the years and even the famous ben
drowned creepypasta you see there are
two big differences between link's
statue and the other statues one the
other statues are created from snapshots
of dead souls and link is not dead
contrary to semi-popular belief and two
while other statues faces look sad or
horrified link's statue's face is
smiling a strange knowing terrifying
smile that's haunted gamers for over two
decades one thing that the statue tells
us about link is that he still has his
soul and he himself is not currently
dead because his statue's eyes are blue
and not white or blank like the other
ones but the question is if the
mysterious power of the elegy of
emptiness reaches into the other side of
death to snapshot the soul of a body if
link's soul is still here in the mortal
realm then just what is link's empty
statue a picture of well since link
himself is still alive and has no
presence in the realm of death what if
the elegy statue is a picture of death
itself specifically link's inevitable
death manifested as a physical
expression you see everybody dies
everybody including link when the elegy
was called upon to find link's soul on
the other side it found nothing so it
duplicated his physical form instead of
his soul but it couldn't help knowing
that this was only temporary eventually
one day maybe soon link's soul would
leave his body and pass into death
somehow some way but inevitably all the
same and that bit of terrifying
knowledge of inevitable death made its
smile at link
or maybe just maybe
it was smiling
at you
[Music]
hey guys thank you so much for watching
this fun little scary theory video
please keep in mind that this was just
my theory and mostly just for fun at
that but i'm still interested in knowing
what you thought of it is the elegy of
emptiness the personification of link's
inevitable death smiling at him as it
awaits him on the other side or is it
still unknown as to why the developers
chose to put such a creepy smile on the
ominous statue let me know in the
comments below and if you would be so
kind leave a like if you liked the video
and subscribe if you haven't already for
much more geeky stuff to come as always
huge thanks to my bandit crew of which i
have a new name to announce say hello to
michael b who recently joined up with my
elite if you watching are interested in
doing the same and helping these videos
get made please feel free to click that
join button located below or follow the
links in my description that's all i've
got for this one so as always i hope
you